a photo op near Ukraine's front lines
the exact location a secret but not far
from bakmut where for months soldiers
have been locked in trench warfare with
the Russians
president zielinski handed out medals
and told soldiers of their country's
gratitude December the 6th his Armed
Forces Day in Ukraine
I would like if you don't mind to
commemorate fellow servicemen who were
killed people who were close to you and
who were by your side while defending
our country and who will remain in our
memory forever I would like to hold a
moment of silence
Medici
and home at last for 60 Ukrainian
prisoners of War swapped for 60 Russians
more than 1 000 prisoners of War have
been exchanged since February it's clear
why Ukraine is particularly thankful to
its Armed Forces they've made huge
sacrifices in lives and limbs to prevent
Russia's Invasion from succeeding but
the toll on civilians is continuing too
on Monday Russia launched the latest
round of missile strikes targeting
Ukraine's energy infrastructure power
was knocked out once again in some parts
of Ukraine and several civilians were
killed
at a Red Cross Point in Kiev displaced
people from occupied or war-torn areas Q
for Aid the above fled russian-held
militar two months ago
at the moment I can't be with my husband
our child is crying asking for him our
whole life was there my brothers are in
the armed forces I have friends fighting
I just want peace so that everything
will return to as it was before
Ukraine has much to be thankful for this
Armed Forces Day but so much too to
mourn Rory challenge Al Jazeera give